revellers in times square
on january 1st 2020 expressed the usual
optimism about the new year
this is our year it's going to be a
great year
little did they know that where they
were standing would in just a few months
due to the coronavirus pandemic
become a ghost town what a difference a
year makes
this december 31st there will be no
crowds here in times square
as in so many other cities around the
world the pandemic is putting a damper
on
celebrations this year the glimmering
crystal ball will still count the world
down into a new year
but the hundreds of thousands of people
who normally line up the blocks and
brave the elements will be reduced to a
small group
of invited guests
[Music]
carson daly who's been in times square
on new year's eve for nbc since 2004
is adapting i don't think it's going to
be like happy new year it's two minutes
away and
all the you know the background
obviously is going to be completely
different you know usually if you see me
on time square you know i'm like hey
where are you from where are you from
were you oh you drove from here you flew
from peru
it's so exciting here guys the tradition
of often shivering crowds assembling
shoulder to shoulder in times square to
ring in the new year as the ball drops
dates back more than a hundred years
there have been only two years when the
ball
didn't drop 1942 and 1943
when the ceremony was suspended due to
the wartime dim out of lights in new
york city
but this year the show will go on staged
for an
at-home audience according to the
president of the times square alliance
which helps coordinate the event
there will be a live broadcast event in
times square but there will not be
a public audience it will simply be
a broadcast stage for the entire world
to see bring in a year that has to be
better
broadcasters will be live without the
raucous crowds below
celebrate with us you sort of have to
kind of nail the tone on a night like
this because this has been just a
horrific year for so many because lives
have been lost
not to mention if it wasn't lives it was
livelihoods
so and then there's some people that you
know may not have been affected so
and everything in between so the tone i
think is is to be
um you know optimistic and hopeful but
reflective
the nypd will bar the general public
from congregating anywhere near times
square
the only people that will be there
besides the performers will be
about 40 people who are our invited
special guests
in years past the onstage production
featured special guests who joined the
mayor in pressing the waterford button
that triggers the ball drop
this year first responders frontline and
essential workers will be the ones
honored
but they'll remain in socially distant
seating areas with their families
rather than pressing the countdown
button
the audience will also include a small
group of guests who've rented for the
night this dome
on nasdaq's terrace overlooking times
square
airbnb which debuted on nasdaq earlier
in december
says the guests who signed up for this
marketing gimmick are paying 21
new york isn't alone in finding ways to
adapt new year's celebrations to the
pandemic
some cities are canceling them
altogether as americans start the day on
december 31st
sydney will kick off the new year with a
scaled-down version of its annual
fireworks display
hong kong is doing away entirely with
its fireworks display over victoria
harbor
officials say it's due to the pandemic
the government also canceled it last
year
citing the threat posed by
anti-government protesters
london now in lockdown has cancelled all
public events
including its fireworks show and las
vegas
which earlier launched an ad campaign to
let people know it's open again
won't hold its annual pyrotechnics
display on the strip
instead the city is promoting a virtual
event where it plans to blow up a 2020
sign
live at an undisclosed location
here in new york city where they've been
around twenty thousand deaths from covid
the organizers of the event say they
want the tone despite the pandemic
to be celebratory and hopeful
staring at the ball being a part of such
a rich american
iconic visual of this ball dropping
i feel like will really make people feel
like okay it's official now it's 20 21
and a sense of relief and a sense of
hope
and in a nod to the year that was
two-time grammy award winner gloria
gainer will sing the lyrics
go on now walk out that door just turn
around now
you're not welcome anymore which i think
is the way we all feel about 2020.
the message from public officials
worldwide you can help make
2021 a year to celebrate by spending new
year's
at home